what's up folks I'm Walter Bernays yak
and this is top five here we countdown
the best and worst performances of our
most beloved actors today we take a look
at the worst of officer Tom Hanson
himself Johnny Depp last week we
highlighted his best and there are many
more good performances than bad for
Johnny Depp but his record is not
unblemished I really respect him for
taking so many risks as an actor he's
not afraid to try new things
the issue with taking those risks though
is that sometimes they pay off but other
times well you'll see these are his top
five worst performances number five
Frank Cappello
in the tourists Johnny Depp and Angelina
Jolie in an action mystery thriller
right American Frank Cappello is taking
a trip through Europe when he runs into
the alluring Elise Clifton ward their
innocent flirting quickly evolves into a
dangerous chase that involves gangsters
and the police when they suspect Frank
of being Elise's criminal significant
other Alexander Pierce the main problem
here is there's absolutely no chemistry
between death and Jolie nothing about
their interactions are ever interesting
or feel authentic at all this affects
their delivery and performances depth
seems like he's sleepwalking through
this one he's really boring just like
this movie and yes I know he's supposed
to be playing a regular schlub but how
about some kind of emotional reaction to
anything please don't
so I've done something wrong please you
can't do this I haven't done anything I
shouldn't be here this also has the most
predictable twist ending ever this is
just about as boring a movie as Depp has
ever done and I think he knows it
number four doctor will cast her in
transcendence yes the tourist is boring
and Depp looks bored in it but his
performance in transcendence makes that
look like Brando in The Godfather doctor
will cast her is the worldwide leader in
the creation of the most highly advanced
artificial intelligence on earth when
extremists try to kill him his wife
Evelyn has one idea to save his
consciousness put his mind into a
computer where he can live up after
expanding his influence to building a
whole technological sanctuary Evelyn
starts to question wills motives and she
starts to think like many others that
this version of will may not be the same
one who physically died this is Wally
Pfister's directorial debut he's usually
Christopher Nolan's director of
photography and a damn good one
while the ideas presented in
transcendence are intriguing they don't
live up to what could be done with the
material and depth at no point looks
like he wants to be there yes he plays a
guy who gets sick then turns into a
computer but even before that Deb's
performance is the flattest I've ever
seen from him it's like he doesn't even
care he barely finishes his own
sentences isn't that what man has always
done eventually Depp's character does
return to a physical body and even then
there's no trace of the man who brought
us all those great performances I
understand will is more of an
introverted character but we needed
something from him at some point that
resembled some sort of emotion dissing
deal Dean dealer Sarah farewell
oh sorry number three
Charlie Mordecai in Mordecai here's an
example of depth trying out something
new in a performance that he clearly
gave us all to unfortunately it's pretty
far down below the bar for a giant deaf
performance based on the Carole
bonfigliano Ville series
Mordecai fouls its goofy titular
character on an adventure to find a
stolen Goya painting this painting is
also said to have a code to a bank
account filled with Nazi gold as
Mordecai finds out he's not the only
person after the painting and this
results in some wacky hijinx throughout
his globe-trotting escapades this seems
like Johnny Depp's best impersonation of
a bad Mike Meyers performance the laughs
are scarce in this one it's even hard
for me to understand what he's saying a
lot of the time Mordecai is just too
obnoxious to carry his own movie I can
maybe see this character working in a
supporting role in a different movie but
here it's just an overload of annoyance
I took a chord vague memory of her
having once involuntarily one would hope
releasing a part of such frightening
power and timbre that I feared she had
done herself a horrible mischief Deb
goes for broke here but is he funny as
Mordecai no no no no no no
now the only thing I thought kind of
work was the jack Mordecai relationship
that provides a few chuckles and depths
chemistry of Paul Bettany is at least
entertaining the watch over although
mordecai as a movie and a performance
was a big misfire for depth later career
there were talks of this being a comedy
franchise for lionsgate but the box
office returns seemed to have said
otherwise number two guy in the punt in
tusk
I don't like tusks like at all I love
Kevin Smith and I loved some of his
older movies I'm also a big fan of the
man himself but this movie is just too
weird and depth fell right into the
madness with his Canadian Inspector
character podcaster wallace bryton tries
to get an interview with a strange old
man with an extraordinary past however
what ensues is a horrific nightmare
involving a walrus that has the American
wishing he never traveled into the true
north death isn't in this movie for all
that long but boy did he make an
impression
much like Mordecai just having an accent
doesn't make a character funny crossing
your eyes doesn't either
in his few scenes depth just seems to be
rambling it feels like a lot of his
lines are ad-lib and they just left it
in because I thought it was funny once
again and off-the-wall character like
this may have worked in another movie
maybe in a movie where he's more
restrained but here it's a little
overboard he has a flashback scene with
Howard Howe and the bad accents bouncing
off each other are almost unbearable
have you ever been to poutine weeny on
Rue de jour
poutine really does not agree
oh my innards it creates such a
poutine gives me the just the worst
shits I wasn't able to see yoga hozier
so is he worse than that let me know in
the comments and the number one worst
Johnny Depp performance is Willy Wonka
and Charlie and the Chocolate Factory I
know they're going to be a lot of
defenders for this film but I don't care
I'm saying this is one of the most
ridiculous unnecessary remakes in
Hollywood history I can't stand Johnny
Depp as Willy Wonka this fantastical
story of Charlie buckets quest to find a
golden ticket and the following tour of
Willy Wonka's chocolate factory is told
in this adaptation of Roald Dahl's
classic book the true motivations for
Wonka's tour slowly present themselves
as one by one the small group of
children and their parents windle's down
as the exploration progresses oh and it
sucks you know you screwed up when the
real Willy Wonka takes your movie as an
insult I think it's an insult to do that
with Johnny Depp who who I think is a
good actor and I like him but I don't
care for that director and he's a
talented man but I don't care for him
for doing stuff like he did
since Gene Wilder recently passed away I
think we can all once again look back
and realize just how special his Willy
Wonka portrayal was you're not supposed
to compare one performance to another
for the same character but it's
impossible in this situation making this
movie was a fool's errand and Depp put
himself right in the line of fire when
he agreed to be the new Willy Wonka he
also didn't make it any better with the
choices he made to play him the way he
did you've heard the comparisons to
Michael Jackson and other strange
personas but I can't 100% blame Depp on
this Tim Burton had to have a huge hand
in crafting this version of that
character and when you let someone go
that far off the rails it's your job as
a director to rein that actor in and get
him back on track Tim Burton didn't do
that with Depp in this movie and
basically hung him out to dry
Depp's Wonka is more of a kid than the
ones he's entertaining and that's not
what the point of this character is
supposed to be you know all those hips
jazzy super cool neat keen and groovy
cats
it's in the fridge daddy yo are you hep
to the jaw can you dig what I'm laying
down I knew that you could slide me some
skin so brother I've heard from some
that this is more accurate to the book
but who cares it fails as a film the
songs are awful the cg environments are
awful and the purposely creepy images
have no point introducing Wonka's father
was something we didn't need either
Willy Wonka is a mysterious character
and that's one of the reasons he was so
great unless we knew about him the
better when I was talking about risks
earlier this is one of the biggest of
Depp's career it didn't pay off but it
took guts to try and recreate this
character when we look back Johnny Depp
will probably be remembered as one of
the best actors in American film history
so all in all I can look past his bad
performances pretty easily I want to
hear what you guys think what is your
least favorite giant Depp movie and our
performance what do you want me to cover
next on the show leave a comment and let
me know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter and come back next
week for a brand spanking new episode of
top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you